okay uh donald trump's press secretary
and senior campaign advisor kaylee
mcinanny
held a press briefing yesterday and if
anything has become clear in the last
five weeks
it's that she is absolutely determined
and committed to going down with the
ship
in the most humiliating way possible
kaylee mcinanna you may remember it
feels like a decade ago but it was not
that long ago i don't remember how long
ago it was on her first day in the press
briefing room as white house press
secretary
kaley promised the media she would never
lie to them
and she would never lie to the american
people but
i know i know but uh she's she's done
nothing but lie ever since
so let's look at some highlights or
really i guess they would be low lights
from what is closer and closer to being
her last briefing as white house press
secretary
she's asked the question understandably
logically
about the fact and it is a fact that the
electoral college has voted
will donald trump now acknowledge that
he lost given
that the electoral college has voted on
monday and without a shred of irony
kaylee mcinanny refers the question to
the campaign
of which she is a senior advisor
remember
now that the electoral college has voted
does the president acknowledge that joe
biden is the president-elect does he
have any plans to invite him here to the
white house
um the president is still involved in
ongoing litigation related to the
election
uh yesterday's vote was one step in the
constitutional process so
i will leave that to him and refer you
to the campaign for more on that
litigation
what is his reaction to leader mcconnell
today congratulating
joe biden and calling him the
president-elect i haven't gotten the
president's reaction to that yet but the
president
um again is pursuing ongoing litigation
would refer you to the campaign for
further
what's the point forward though for
litigation if the votes have been
certified if the electoral college has
voted there doesn't seem to be a legal
recourse at this point
the campaign would have more specifics
for you on legal recourse but yesterday
was one step in the constitutional
process
leading up to the january 20th date in
the constitution
this is such a tired farcical game that
she's been playing
if it's convenient she's the white house
press secretary
and if it's convenient she's the white
house if she's the trump campaign senior
advisor
and you're going to have to ask the
other entity about that
that that question it's actually
completely embarrassing at this point
and she doesn't care
she just keeps using that to avoid
answering questions
no question is simple for kaylee
mcinanni the answer is always weird
she was asked a pretty straightforward
question will trump
take the vaccine and she says trump is
open to taking the vaccine well but will
he take it
we don't actually get an answer to that
part does the president plan to take the
vaccine and really do it in a public way
to inspire confidence among people
so the president um currently at this
moment has said he is
absolutely open to taking the vaccine
he's been emphatic about that
to me privately and to you all publicly
but he did recently recover from covid
he has the continued protective effects
of the monoclonal antibody cocktail that
i mentioned
and he will receive the vaccine as soon
as his medical team determines its best
but
his priority is frontline workers those
in long-term care facilities and he
wants to make sure that the vulnerable
get
access first yes wouldn't be taking the
vaccine set an example for americans to
give them confidence
doctors uh dr bauchi as well as the
month of louis both said today
that they think president trump should
get the vaccine if
they you know because for himself would
be to set an example
will he do that like why not do it just
to show americans that it's safe
because he also wants to show americans
that our priority are the most
most vulnerable there will be some
senior administration officials taking
it publicly to instill that confidence
it is very important
this is not merely a cop-out answer
it's actually dangerous because kaylee
cites as a reason maybe trump doesn't
need the vaccine the fact that he had
coronavirus and recovered for it so he
has naturally derived immunity
that's still a question mark why when
you know that the followers of this
president
are disproportionately anti-science
trump brown-nosers who will do anything
they can
to excuse behaving less safely we don't
know how long immunity lasts after a
recovery from the virus that's an open
question
we don't know whether you have stronger
longer-lasting more robust immunity
if you recover from a serious case of
the virus versus if you had one of those
asymptomatic cases we just these are
open questions and it's irresponsible
for her to be saying that maybe trump
doesn't really need the vaccine
or needs it less because he recovered
for the from the virus
cdc guidelines and equivalent guidelines
around the world from
from other country health agencies
are regardless of whether you've had the
virus when a vaccine becomes available
you should get the vaccine
moving on kaylee again says that donald
trump
will veto military funding partially
because he's angry at twitter
do you know when specifically when the
president will veto the national defense
authorization act when he's going to
send the paperwork over
and why would he veto that given the
fact that passed on veto proof
majorities in congress
so he still does plan to veto the ndaa
i don't have a timeline for you on that
but he does plan to veto it
um he wants to make every effort to
protect our military men and women
and will prioritize military funding in
the big omnibus bill but
he also has other important priorities
and i should say problems with the ndaa
beyond just the absence of section 230
repeal
and beyond the inclusion of the warren
amendment one of the
provisions of concern is troop
provisions about troop withdrawal and
deployment in afghanistan south korea
and germany and so there are a number of
provisions that um
so i let me remind you about that trump
has talked about this section 230 thing
section 230 is a provision
which essentially says that
if there is uh illegal libelous
or otherwise uh problematic content
on a platform like twitter or youtube it
is not twitter or youtube that are
liable
it's whoever posts it that is liable and
donald trump
believes that if you eliminate section
230
a lot of anti-trump trends would be shut
down like for example
when donald trump sat at that tiny desk
and
attacked people on thanksgiving day and
then the hashtag
diaperdon trended on twitter diaper
dawn's sort of an allusion to
um the petulant child that is donald
trump
trump went crazy talking about section
230 section 230 if we get rid of it
twitter would never allow diaper dawn to
trend now
there's really no legal liability with
diaper don a hashtag about
not just a public person but one of the
most powerful public figures in the
world
so that actually wouldn't change diaper
dawn from trending
but what trump seems not to understand
is that if section 230 is eliminated he
likely gets banned from twitter
because of the things he posts to
twitter which are
wrong public health disinformation
election disinformation
posts that direct bullying against
individuals
trump seems to think his problems go
away if section 230 goes away
in fact he probably gets banned from
twitter if section 230 goes away all
right so that's
that's that to get back on track kaylee
continues to allude to
a second trump term starting on january
20th
it's all coded language but here she
refers to
listen we're ready for a transition
and we're also ready for a continuation
of power and either might happen
the electoral college has voted it it's
over but kaylee continues to to play
this game
biden's cabinet picks uh president trump
had the benefit of the senate
starting hearings and starting the
process before he was inaugurated in
january
of 2017. does the president oppose
the senate taking up uh joe biden's
nominees before
the inauguration i think that's a
hypothetical um and you know he won't
get ahead of
that activity actually happening but he
has taken all statutory
requirements um necessary to and either
ensure a smooth transition or a
continuation of power
just absolutely out of her mind there's
no
there's no caveat here there's no
mitigating factor
she's just pushing nonsense the
electoral college voted
on monday uh joe biden has 270 actually
306
electoral votes they're gaslighting
people that's all it is
and they continue to raise money on it
trump as recently as yesterday sending
out emails saying
i need to raise a million dollars in the
next
hour or day or whatever it was um kaylee
asked why hasn't donald trump been more
visible during the vaccine rollout i
mean this is this is happening
and shouldn't he be there we barely see
the president where has he been he has
nothing on his schedule ever
and uh kaylee with a straight face says
it's because trump's been so busy
working
why hasn't president trump been more
visible
during this initial vaccine rollout you
have the vice president
in indiana today where's president trump
president trump's been hard at work on
kovid behind the scenes just because you
don't see him at the podium every day
doesn't mean that he's not aggressively
pursuing actions on behalf of the
american people
he's briefed on covid regularly and i'm
here speaking with you guys others
are out communicating this information
all the things she's talking about
working behind the scenes meetings
working on kovid
his public schedule is blank every day
it is the argument now of course
when the president there are things that
are off a president's public schedule
that the president does
uh but is the argument that just like
having meetings about the vaccine
are so secret that they can't even be on
trump's schedule it's just more lies
trump is doing nothing
every report from inside the the white
house is that trump is doing nothing
and then the sort of denumont here as
she walks out
is j she she of course walks out after
taking very few questions and not
answering any of them
in in any real way you hear in this next
clip as she's walking out of the press
briefing room
i love this cnn's jim acosta asking
kaylee isn't it hypocritical for you to
accuse others of spreading
disinformation when you spread it every
day
a beautiful question someone like trump
might call it a nasty question
but it's an important question take a
listen really interesting turn of events
and good for those who covered what was
a story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it
hypocritical for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day
in a logical world okay if actions had
logical consequences
no one would want to employ kaylee
mcinanny after this absolute insanity of
a white house press secretary tenure
unfortunately we know
that she uh likely is going to end up
with some kind of very cushy gig
either i don't know as a consultant at
some
right-wing organization or doing
communications for
a company that has right-wing leanings
or who knows but she is going to have a
very soft landing don't
if she should be unemployable based on
the deceit and the lies
but she's going to have a fine landing
if you were worried about where kaylee
goes after this don't you don't don't
worry about it at all
we'll have more coverage of this and
clips on the show's instagram page at
david pakman show
and if you want to see what happened to
my umbrella in very very powerful boston
winds
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david.pacman a video that
has taken
uh i guess i was going to say the world
by storm not really a video that has
taken my followers
by storm me barely able to handle
an umbrella in boston wind that's on my
personal instagram david.pacman
we'll take a quick break up next mitch
mcconnell he finally did it
what is it that he did we'll talk about
it in two minutes
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale
on all of their products right now and
you can take advantage of it by going to
davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch
really is the perfect way to add
something
fresh to your style whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else
vincero is a brand that has a serious
dedication to the craft of watchmaking
which is really evident when you look
closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black
watch and i love the sleek minimalist
design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
five-star reviews because you won't find
a better made
watch for this great of a price anywhere
else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video